non so se siamo partiti io c'ho sempre
questa ansia che non capisco se è
partito meno però bella ciao ragazzi
come state alla misura portale vi sono
c'è una bella persona di qualità in hd
scusatemi abbiamo fatto i settaggi come
la merda ma perché ci siamo svegliati di
tipo adesso quindi all e ciao belle
persone come state sono qui con i box
con gli occhiali da sole sta luce che
che cacchio effettivamente io sono
abituato ormai riguardo alla luce come
se guardassi gesù però effettivamente le
persone normali con degli occhi normali
devono indossare gli occhiali da sole
perché sta roba è veramente la divinità
sulla terra però è bello da siete
bellissimi ragazzi con divina roba
nell'altra streaming che avevo fatto
l'altro giorno al liceo della gente a
caso mi ha donato tipo dei tipo 10 euro
del genere che ho detto che io ho detto
il live con ondulate perché non riesco a
leggere i messaggi visto che non pensavo
che fosse la tv alle donazioni con la
super chat dico bene adesso donate tutti
grazie perché ho puntato 35 euro sulla
vittoria di mcgregor e gli ho presa
veramente nel culo quindi grazie ai 35
euro
arriviamo a 30 c colori donazioni che
almeno mi riprende i soldi nella puntata
mahroug ha dichiarato allora il fatto è
che poi ho chiamato suri e perché anche
puntare su mcgregor e mi fa perché solo
i punta più di 35 euro colossi come eni
fa e gli faccio ma quante puntando su
mcgregor io ho perso 35 euro tu e lui mi
risponde non ho puntato niente alla fine
perché non era riuscito ad avviare la
live la diretta dell'incontro miglia
fine non ha perso un cazzo io penso 35
euro tornate insomma basta vogliamo i
soldi di voli accogliamo vogliamo i 35
euro persi da me però comunque
complimenti a mcgregor che ha fatto il
culo io che mi intendo di bosco
bellissimo cazzo cazzo
e allora tanto mi sa che non era
negativa su facciate ma va bene lo
stesso dove avviene il pensiero capisco
e e niente ragazzi oggi faremo un player
non batterio ams lo so che tutti quanti
ere orecchie venerdì 13 no
oggi dobbiamo fare i culi quindi io oggi
facciamo in cui in un mega gut muggas ci
siete centrato su un non volte grande ma
tanto siamo in live ricerca siamo il
live avevamo parlando da sé contrasti
25.000 spettatori ciao persone belle a
giuste
quello che sono
allora dobbiamo in sei madonna perso 35
euro come di regola per strada ed è
facilmente più ansia l'incontro di ieri
io vi dico che siccome l'incontro c'è
stato alle 6 del mattino tipo mi sono
svegliato guardate il primo round
poi ho perso tutti i nove dopo che ha
sbagliato all'ultimo fatturato è invece
sei rimasto sveglio
infatti sono distruttissima porca vacca
lachapelle io drama no a questa cosa qua
non di quelle maschili sono le da
invitami così come non si fa ce la
faccio io dimitri la banca parli
agr e devi fare carino e ciao scusa mi
sono il live non posso rispondere allora
rispetto che mettono invitano tutti play
l'ex che le schiere start ed by play off
alla ragazzi giocheremo come lo schifo
però molti ho già detto che non avete
chiesto perché ho messo gerry scotti
nella copertina
la risposta è perché no di scotti va
bene ovunque un po come il prezzemolo
diviene ed io gestisco magia e gerry
scotti ok non so quanto riusciremo a
fare poi 300 punti inter carica prima
che più veloce il mio io sta cosa non la
capisco telo lucia venissero bello e
quindi non riesco a capirla questa cosa
incapibile infatti dai quanto tempo
quant'altro 6 si sta vedendo un effetto
contagio è che la nonna ha cup
pubblicità la playstation gratis così
perché mi va mai e sanchez
siamo mai
se siamo si aspetta che mischia
percolato per 26 la madonna che bella
live questa partita ma inutile l'atomica
6 guarda guarda lo gira la visuale
ok era impazzito facciamo con
controllante godini quasi la tv the ok
che faccio mcgregor e non li voglio
questi 35 nemico
ho speso 30 bastardo lui qui sta
combattendo ieri per non farmi perdere
ma non per la gloria di sciacca che se
avrete forti o tappe sono vestito come
guardo e visto come volto
allora la pasta questo bellissimo ma
aereo allora l'altro giorno abbiamo
vinto ovviamente non erano che il laico
però adesso perderemo perché siamo in
light come sempre colaianni ciò che
tutti i gelati
credeva che facciamo così
ma che ci siamo alzati un'ora fa perché
sono date nomi alle 7 del mattino
neanche un mar qui neanche si è
svegliato adesso k live sono tre
miracoli
la smania poliani a jasnaja poljana vai
321 via vai sul bene siamo arrivati a
250mila euro di donazioni grazie così
almeno ormai quali preso la puntata non
sto scherzando ovviamente la mi sa che
la chat e all'abitabilità dami non è
arrivato niente ma non importa
va bene il pensiero alla prossima 1
scommetto più ti sei accorto che stai
cadendo dritto per terna pollica di una
mazza e perché perché teramo in assise
nel mio amministrata serie modo
sbagliato nell open data sei solo un
chilo vedono in via nei cantieri si tira
giù una ciabatta
non si dica che non abbiamo nessuno
magoni sul liscio vicino adesso chiedo
se sei bocca si può più sbocchi bar
allora forse c'è anche una macchina e
non vorrei esagerare dall'alto dovreste
riuscire a vedere qualcosa di decente
perché non vedo una minchia comunque non
è caduto niente quasi come un detto che
un tizio porca vacca infame maledetto se
per esempio quando una città il signor
sono altro che minchia tipo mi fan culo
che non farà che mandarono strumenti no
no non ti preoccupare se volete la quale
macchina 0 aiuto non mi ha preso le
presento squadra di storia c'è giretti
andy basta usciamo
ma no ma poi ma poi iniziato a spararmi
quello si è girato ma sparato genoa
stende già morto te lo giuro
no ma in una maniera incredibile cillo
gli spazi e le quote al a [ __ ] a da
lucio ma siamo matti
il gioco di man basta mi sono rotto le
palle
ciao ciao vai tu hai via via vai via
vieni qua temi del processo ma chi la
ignora sono cagare cribbio
non c'e verso pescara dove siete scesi
sulla rai asinaria balljana però c'era
un tizio sul tempo gli ho sparato un
esegeta un'altra donna uccisa in quel pc
armati di gomma porca vacca
com'è possibile spiegano ci sono
atterrato invece dall'altra parte del
mondo
ecco quindi seguendo le 26 molto bravo
dell'altro e anche perché sa fare
ritocchi al bomber da 264 limone gregor
in cui madonna quali chance ma secondo
me a dirti che si comincia a picchiare 1
arriva notizia di chiaro perché è poi
che la pressione del successo della
positiva non penso che dai g data
picchiarlo scolpito e mezzo di
comunicazione sportello colletti sì è
vero guarda però voti che ha fatto
questo
così a caso superman punch va bene basta
capiamoci bene dice che i capelli a
questo cos'è e mail riguarda locazione è
bellissimo c'è problema
lei da iaia e stavolta vo primi una
geniale prima ultimi punti
i primi ad uscire dagli ultimi radio
saranno i primi e veniamo dove andiamo
quasi l ho 5
la sinistra
comparti
il live fondo non siamo il libro di via
qua è perché siamo il live moriano
1 via puccini tipo volare così alla
carica di brutto
c 68
voglioso sta raggiungendo una velocità
incredibile 500 chilometri erano 220
prima 130 e le giuste 130 e si vola ce
n'è un'altra grossa è mica solo uno ma
ci sono almeno 63 ed emma ecco capi
seconda maratona sono picciotto perché
giustamente raccomandabile mancine
veramente troppi e vabbè dai la guerra e
questa mica giocare con le bambole vai
sulle case io ho visto che meno dove
sono atterrati vedi league
stammi vicino però sono contento però
spider man
6 cosa è successo ma global data oppure
perché l'amore va che assurdo vabbè io
il primo a casa quando riscattare una
pistola del genere per ora niente o sks
subito subito atac
sì però il meetup ermini non ce la
mettono a casa perché c'è la sks
regatato cecchino subito madonna ha
portato squadra votate il mirino per il
check in e te lo giuro c'era mai
successo starà poi muoio e un secondo
dopo però almeno trovato sta roba sono
contento micky incredibile il cecchino
la prima cosa subito ma va bene così
però adesso ci dobbiamo riunire ci
riuniamo ci siamo quasi
tu sei anche stabilito una partita ma
dobbiamo essere
infatti dichiarano do a te no da subito
mi sarebbe andati in quella rossa
davanti la vedi però sono sicuro di
questo
io non so bene effettivamente no no non
morirà nota
no a me no però il fraseggio 8 piccinini
non morire fai le cose giuste ma non
siamo ultimi anni andò dal km trovate
tutte chi quando sentono per capelli di
kucka veloso
dopo una cappa è che ti sto lasciando
c'era in arma vari storia cucina è
bruttissimo allora prendiamo la cacca pt
6 colpi per la km no no
vienna 22 34 proprio per terra in una
capitale si sta sparando quindi queste
cose uno zaino c'erano 40 qua arrivo
livello 2 e pula aspetta chi è chi sta
sparando me lo capisco da dove poi non
lo so ora erano molto vicini secondo
massimo lottando le case sfruttando le
case le che possono far altro che è
medico qua di yahoo
ok
adesso aspettiamo sanno di smile anno di
studi chi è che ha aperto la porta da
non vedo nessuno sdram poi come andiamo
deciso non 26 fermi massacrante
comperiamo già un micio micio messi
abbastanza bene mentre e gas gas
stiamo detto la safe visto tre foglietti
parlare mi sembrava una persona infatti
capire tutto né per lucky madonna che
peso ci stiamo
dai muoviamoci ci siamo sempre qua no
però il problema è che in nove anni a un
nuovo articolo vediamo che trattare
l'addio non sommato questa cosa possa
rendere questo essere utile ai fini
nell'operazione sono atterrato di volo
nava radici con l'under allo stato o
giochi sono forti
l'educazione
occhio e quando entri nei portici la
gente contentissima pensai
[Musica]
medici che stanno già cambiando
ma sicuramente 52
so che quando visuale migliore allora ci
sono porte aperte quindi sono passati
sicuro è che davanti a noi più o meno
300 però non ne vedo un mezzo ma è anche
uno salmo macchine tu l'hai vista mentre
scendere
sì l'ho vista ma non erano non più
utilizzabili perché sono ancora qui di
fianco sarebbe una cosa normalissima mi
servono m4 un amico l'ha vista della
fine scendere qua è stato meglio di
prima ma c'era un volto di gente visto
ragazzo è appunto ora perché quello che
sta accadendo dopo che avremo che
ritorna dunque 45 laici come fai a
saperlo
poi l'ho sentito c'è dietro di noi no a
240 recente a 309
o comunque dura ma chi spara sono
davanti se vi sono davanti a vedrai
chiamano verificarsi ti togli 9 mi ruba
the police ha bisogno di perché mi hanno
dieci soldati e inter entra subito il
comites copertissimo dialogo
cos'è successo molto giuliese rubato i
gol di no o ma un m 4 schifosissimo lo
troviamo guardarmi hai tu cosa c'è ke ha
la cappa e cosa ora ci siamo con la k de
vita appare perché michele metodi per
trarne viste salta la mano capito che si
reca comunque è arrivato anche nuove
scorte dio nell occhio in vasca sia
sempre più capillari stessa secondo me
mezzo alla città non ci saranno mai le
macchine poteva valutare perché ormai se
ne saranno andati lì per i futuri
occhio però sempre
[Musica]
base
vedo
ho trovato gente la gente non accetterò
del piccolo subito allora macchina
macchina a macchina macchina può fuori 3
ci dovrebbero essere più sentite a
scendere no no no ecco adesso l'ho
sentita macchina da berna ha dietro di
noi dove siamo tematica è passata la
sento anch'io andata via
non so dove però sentivo andata via
mica ci serve una macchina sicura perché
per la respinge chi dovremmo correre
come delle lepri
chiamava me weatherill del rais
la marca dove dove era nascosto in una
casa bastardo ma qualche malissimo
questa qua è l'angolo di progetto guarda
non c'era un altro bastardo cioè
proseguendo a solo bra serviva tutto
troppo oggi la partita tranquillamente
faccia sinceramente grandi porca vacca
nel morto l'altro è la dietro che mi
aspetta non voleva che non vedessi
chiaro già visti figure levati arriva
nokia non c'era la granata ma ho notato
visita ma che cosa faceva una vita altro
scusami di vita io sono abbastanza
tranquillo
no ovviamente attimo però
no non riesco a scendere aiuto quanti
problemi nel scendere da una casa e come
faccio nomi sciattamente tutte vicende
non è spiacente l'aiuto amici non so
scavalcare un muro dei problemi non sono
studiato non sono allenato allora porca
vacca non riesca a scendere la sul
problema è uscito la chiara citato
randazzo ciao
e stato bello e per forza che non posso
mica sta cosa fanno le donne non da solo
ecco ecco tutti gli all in
grandissimo
bombardano celato di me scusami dire
grazie
accordo biennale dove dove e
l'irriverenza devo andar via di qua in
bombardano in faccia poi a me ma poi
chiamata anche fastidio qualcosa none
massa gioca in prima del mare vabbè
riproviamoci gli anni degli illusi a
pollegio le schiere caldo fare sono
veramente io devo mettere il ventilatore
power climatizzato minchia
ma la bellezza dell'ascella commentiamo
orca
66 carico mai questa nostra mi ha fatto
spaventare tantissimo quindi aperte via
pertica che hanno fatto ieri ha cioè
quello schiacciano questo mi ha premuto
saremo tanto era quindi dietro
ti diverti a picchiare gli altri mentre
sono invece making si è battuta con
questo che cos'è cos'è è una falce si è
dottore ellis voglio ammazzare qualcuno
con una pace quindi a casa
allora
basta a cazzeggiare certo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
si no
primark
al.cia
gergo
no rosa
andranno tutti però andranno vanno a
vigente li caga però
1 vai
due davanti a noi
pasolini sarebbe voteranno prima in
città ma anche come pietro a destra
da quattro anni a quanta gente viene qui
bisogno di lottare o quan
siemens ha una voce gente gente gente a
sei in mezzo un po troppi
e vabbè le mazze lo tutti io ho la
fiducia mi ha sempre operato mi hanno
anche una macchina non solo decadono
come cadono gli altri al di sopra tutto
qua ce n'è un altro che è venuto qua mi
morire per favore facciamo una partita
decente
stacchiamo la line e facciamo un anno
vinciamo però non ho quindici oltre a
vinciamo pro sempre però
ovviamente non c'è nessuna quando nella
casa dopo c'è una vision direttamente a
quando
porca
macchia
sì va bene in case private aspetta
aspetta dice uno
si no
questa spara porca vacca stanno sparando
fortissimo via via via a 64
sono vicino però cerchiamo di macchina
ovviamente gli altri hanno già tutti
armi super paolo tipo quello che ha
sparato la macchina io sono una pistola
in me va beh guarda che non ha visto
perché non ha visto lei è buttato giù
bravo
io i due case non ho trovato mezza arma
e che si dica che sono praticamente
morto subito morto subito immediatamente
sono in mezzo allo schifo totale e
figure aspettano ma tocca non ne ha
beccati forse entra nintendo madonna che
bordello
assist hanno sparato tra di loro figo e
si ksc posso renzi però tanto non mi
riguarda devo scappare su una mina prima
questo
un copione colpack insieme alto si è
niente da non stare più attaccati perché
sono atterrato per pronta però un anno
ucciso tu sei già ampiamente super
skillato ma no solo un capitano
no il mirino neanche quindi cosa ci
faccio tratteremo qualche non c'è
nessuno tra l'altro la zona sicura via
quindi figura si è involata traguardi
nel mondo
ma non fate non uccidono dalla due
particolari e sparate non sparate
14 non valgono sul modo non c'è mai fine
hanno fatto
tanto poi anch'io perché è una maschera
ha già fatto scarica un [ __ ] muretto
e dove c'è gente che camper ali quindi
si spara in faccia per te ne esco fuori
però maestro patemi serve una macchina
punto però
e figure cioè fase di vincere tutto
quanto si stanno sparando
francia
nel cesura
no non si vede se ero io ero già morto
ma [ __ ] ha pure se ero io quello
era già morto e l'organismo non è sola
partita però dettagli ho dato io non ho
imparati come quello prima non mi abbia
visto mentre vista la scena
glielo straiati ceo sodico uscito dalla
casa mi ha passato di fianco correndo è
normalissimo vado a farmi uccidere sera
intanto speranza perché sono troppo
c'erano macchina peccato perché volessi
capaci poi saranno ancora day camp e
raggi x sono tutta la vita sul tetto
se ne escono tutte di vivere
datelo nell idea di dove sia andato e
poi si è volatilizzato
dall'altra parte della serie sì no no
non ci arriva mai ma sì quindi io l'ho
provato andare ad ucciderlo tanto non
morirono tutta la vita ma ci provo
per l'intrattenimento così in cina con
ma in mano magari lo show di cure no non
penso proprio perché dovessero colpirlo
ma sente arrivare a f2i 7 arriva al fico
l'economia massimo da ridire ma sai non
se l'aspettano che questa gente dice che
le lobby si blocca ora che avete della
connessione di mezzo norma perché è
evidente lo stupendo del telefono è
morto beh ce la faremo a farne una come
si deve devo staccare il live on line o
a jeans jesus live
le schede siamo vicini ai tavoli tra
l'altro la mia fantastica magna ma c'è e
cosa ho fatto
aereo a r benissimo
vico cazzo che a bologna prova a farti
dario aereo è un casino ti assicuro
stesso ritardato si toglie precedente ma
perché sono stato allo stesso devi
togliere neanche la posta con
esperimenti come si parla di saltare di
fare così caldo pronuncia forme di
saltara qualche opposto per ma certo ma
io nel silenzio così in tuscia
o 100 donne di stavolta
allora
io comunque escludere legami citate
i tuoi niente vita e al terrore
qua ho qua
papà via archia
credo che uno vai è comunque sarà appena
riguardato non c'è un punto che non va
gente
pensai che forse quattro
non c'è contento in quanto è possibile
che ci siano solo dove sono da mattia
dai sopra samb
stiamo vicini e che uno deve dare
supporto all'altro perché sennò va giù
subito torna indietro quindi che sono le
cose almeno questa me la prendo
dove hanno vissuto le sinistre l'altro
neanche una pistola niente gli altri
presenti hanno già nel cast il nulla e
croato ma nulla ma c'è incredibile ho
una pistola adesso finalmente un eco
scettici assicuri ben
vediamo cosa ci dobbiamo andar via di
qua poi dopo subito qui è messo il
signorino perché tanto la safe è lì che
non ha senso vendiamo dagli altri
capitano si aspettiamo qua ma che
dobbiamo stare a casa la mamma mia e la
madonna gente no
il silenziatore che è molto utile
suo asse col mirino
dovrei anche trovar marzo 2007 troppo
fastidio o si dovesse tasso misto nei
piani che quando hai fatto
andiamo verso punto quindi non c'è
niente
e beh tanto quando troviamo niente
vediamo
mi sono pagato ad office
tempo correndo nicchia
non so se è caduto qualcuno qua credo di
no non è previsto nessun titolo alcuno
vedere oltre
quindi sicuramente
agli amici si va se mi chiedo allora
giorno
non ne ho idea vediamo allora non sono
né idea perché non ho proprio visto sono
sicurissima sei sicuro al mille per
cento mi stanno sparando in faccia dal
nord si no non penso a te non ti hanno
sparato occhio
occhio perché c'è una sparata magari
questo spara abilissimo anche a te vabbè
usciamo andiamo dove dovevamo andare sì
ma io non è possibile che devo andare in
giro con una vista che se aspettiamo ci
ammazzano comunque quindi dobbiamo
muoverci almeno vediamo questo non
appena ingaggiato c6 è vero che non era
però hanno aspetta vieni vieni qua dove
sono io ho avuto l'idea entra in troppo
prendi quell'arma che ce li ha michele
usa questi occhi ammirare che non c'è il
minimo edili nino un cazzo niente
633 d'una bike spareranno forte quindi
vediamo se riusciamo a morire anche se
dubito ci sono e mi chiedo allora si sta
sparando perché non so se sparando
perché aspetta noi siamo in posizione
buona per morire io sul ponte a chiani
non ci passa
no no non so che ci andremo speriamo st
grata in teoria dovremmo essere
abbastanza a posto potrebbe essere anche
là dentro non so dove occhio occhio
perfetto chissà dove minchia mica mi
sembra una macchina alla rumore delle
onde center
pesa pesa questa situa pesa ma ce la
facciamo da chissà chi minchia era bush
ma curioso proprio e la doma insomma più
nella da badante ci ritroviamo davanti
figo
tanto il ghiaccio francamente siamo
dentro subito le case o moriamo
bombardati in faccia in live non è
neanche il massimo morire dal bomber de
maio volta la bontà tanto il live per i
cori forest abbiamo ancora quei dieci
secondi buoni però subito dentro
sperando non ci sia qualcuno si e 12
anni nella prima lontana come 330 che
cela porterà più dia subito perché siano
completamente ci ammazza perché
completamente tante dalla borsa non c'è
niente in sta a casa che significa che
sono già votato per forza porca vacca
infame quanto peso ai a questo siamo
arrivati però incarnato non bruttissima
sta roba
poi dall'altro case fatti di paglia che
tengono bombardamenti
c'è anche la croce da pregare segue
io la vedo guarda
sparita perché sei credente ma gliela
vedovi la croce 59 lì perché occhio che
uscirà forse qualcuno abbiamo sì ma
dobbiamo avere
anzi mi sa che si osi restringersi
umiltà o sulla militari bass e quindi a
questo punto direi anche quasi di
dobbiamo stare qua e di là delle si
restringe
quando tu hai un po
ma c'è
ascolto che arriva a quando non mi sparo
che cazzo
dobbiamo far morire
a me la conta giusta sto posto c'è
qualcuno sicuro
no è però non ci sono armi c'è senso
risultato e 9 dice una porta aperta poi
figura da consigliere che la sua taglia
no no in fondo in fondo
le porte per sempre la giornata è
sicuramente c'è qualcuno non capisco
dove c'è stato sicuramente va dai
pensieri sono perso del nostro passo di
danza
andiamo dove troviamo una macchia soltan
diamo in mezzo alla seta è una partita
anche questo è un po di merda l'abbiamo
trovato niente mirino c'è una sega o
prego che l'abbiano lasciato senza però
accidenti e lo zaino sto arrivando a
symbian
lo vedi giovane ha fatto bene ma spara
come sapete la destra
c'è nessuno casa e la persona pulite
sono aperte tutte prime
secondo me lo zio è andata verso di
quanto noi dobbiamo andare se saprete
percorrendo i punti pd merda di tutta la
mappa però dobbiamo provarci non ho
neanche un mirino c'è proprio lo
schifoso tale che non riusciamo si sta
sparando
così comunque un mirino ottico ma chi
gliel'ha detto ci potrebbe essere sempre
quello che ci sperava prima
quelle sarebbe stato proprio una
macchina c'è una macchina li gialla che
ci serve assolutamente ma se c'è una
macchina 12mila per cento c'è qualcuno
dentro casa andiamo a marina di che
andiamo a morire così riusciamo a volte
li amano non c'era una foto a destra
roma 6 giu una moto si è tanto test
medico del blu no i 30 gradi arrivando
verso le case a una moto che san dana
mai pensavo non ho capito quando davanti
prevista
no però strada dove nel gas si sa perché
c'è una macchina che li inseguono molto
bravi cassetto tom e jerry no
ma c'è qualcuno sicuro dove incuranti la
dacia devo rubargli la macchina tutta la
vita ci provano ci serve troppo la
macchina devo provare le sedi
strafottere mai
vado
[Musica]
non lo sprezzo della mente
sa libro salire la donna quanto fa
schifo sta macchina non sa le attenzioni
non funziona
mica si restringerà se nella
i militari bass porti cavalca il primo
l'amica ripeta
devi mettimi di markers ora kakà verrà
sistemato un successo il fenomeno occhio
minimarket sul monte 9 il problema però
secondo me potrà versare il ponte dove
mandare nella generale nella militari
bestie sarà lei non ci sta
cominciamo a strapparti da vinci fanno
santi ci è impossibile
ma non solo ai pretesi fa
però per dire mica altra macchina a
destra
ma adesso prima di tutto
guarda caso nel silvio tipo
fonte
ma come evita le balle di fieno questo
luogo come sa guidare come non gli danno
la patente ma se la merita
occhio rapaci spalla mentre ci
spareranno nel ponte perché non contempo
il fatto che non ci sia nessuno frega
sicuramente non l'hai mai infatti video
con appalto gli adesso incomincia a
sparare
quello
e più di caso si vabbè tantissimi ma io
non ci credo mi è finita la mensa
definita a benzina potter finora messina
male o è finita la benzina sul pont
incredibile te lo giuro vita la benzina
sul ponte non è successo c'è però assist
proprio nel momento in cui questa bruno
qua dentro le tipo del mimo razza
succedendo tipo
[Musica]
stiamo facendo il sesso dentro la
macchina guarda ma io veramente sono
molto e sono svenuto a 29 giu
oggi non è mai successo mi finita la
benzina sul ponte mentre ci stavano
tutto il campionato cioè stronzi sono
place messia camperare su una ma se
fanno sempre così infatti lo sapevo ci
avrebbero sparato però non pensavo di
fini e la benzina
no no io oggi stato il mito che quando
facciamo le largo e prendiamo sempre
dovevano stato al figlio sto qua fino a
mezzanotte non me frega un cazzo ve lo
giuro su dio ve lo giuriamo che neanche
vinciamo non me ne frega però per gli
hotel almeno rotta non me ne frega
riprendere nisce almeno top ten sì sì no
no no non vincola la juve lo giuro
ragazzi non finiscono perché ogni volta
è perciò una light perdiamo suo gioco
poi ogni volta che sta cola light
facciamo una così a casa e vinciamo
vi giuro vi giuro che non sta cola light
soft perché voglio arrivare in top non
frega un cazzo ve lo giuro succedono
sempre cose completamente negative
mentre sono in live che mi fanno morire
t come è finita la benzina sul ponte mai
successo proprio perché la live attira
cose negative ma non me ne frega un
cazzo oggi vinciamo anche il live è che
abbiamo vinto bene
hai capito a questo punto bologna è per
me
hai capito
sì incazzate un po troppo guarda fantasy
le tattiche
lui pur di napoli si tu no
ciao fatto sì che lo ripaga con sé
grazie a branca se la sta facendo
sembra una cosa sembra tranquillo visto
che si è però se l'era vista schiena
facciamo ma non hanno avviato tutti
indosso ma loro hanno iniziato
a pieni polmoni
ti fermi spiega le altre cose tipo
mentre
su direi siete quanto lo shooting 20 ci
arriveremo mai però so dire 321 vai mai
ci arriveremo ma neanche per sbaglio e
vogliamo forse a sedermi anzi 26 verdini
ci sembra dire la città di khan croce di
range è capito
l'astice nero troppo forte
ma stai scegliendo giusto
quanta gente c'è 126 km era chiuso per
cassa 68 ce ne sono quattro più del 35
no 445 più del previsto
proprio per sempre parte uno di fianco a
me quando mi chiedevo dove sei tu
durante la mia casa è qui dobbiamo
nemmeno delle poche armi c'è uno che è
stata rivista a casa qua no
sì sì sì in questo momento eterna più
quindi io a severino
no non è vero non ci sono stati dei
servi prova
stiamo andando anche noi yoandri una
parte e niente siamo distanti
se non siamo atterrati nessun posto
utile e ma neanche loro capito eh sì
l'avranno sicuramente già anche sono la
pistola ci fanno cuore io sono da sempre
guarda qua da soli dalla nicchia la
macchina alcuni sento l'avanti una
macchina senza diritto le viola niente
figurati se trova l'arma
sentono che io non vedo come la sede
dove sono arrivato a tanto
dobbiamo andare quei giochini niente va
be
prendiamo qualche arma facciamo il culo
perché fare il culo è difficile che
siamo in live
la macchina è ancora lì ha senso ma
lasciando madame sisi ad essere di
crescendo dimezzamento della fatta forza
delle sue forme diciamo qualcuno sito
porca vacca che la brianza no non lo
prendo lo dicevo
spero vivamente le colazioni solo
giustamente c'è qualcuno pare una cazzo
di balestra che cosa me ne faccio la
butti proprio perché secondo qualcuno
spara una pace di volo però comunque
linea massimo
così in quella casa non si
ho trovato le cose di buono se attivo
m16 ma mi trovo le palestre per il resto
nessun pensiero e lo metto qua questo
non l'ho colta manovra
ci dà modo di s
silenziatore
occhio che qui inizia a esserci ho visto
che a tu per tu col a portali c'è un per
quattro che culo che ma io non ho
neanche lo zaino forte di lavarli chi è
un'azione riciclo
assistiamo leccese sono shop
se stiamo vicini e molto meglio perché
non ci ritiriamo sto dicendo la casa
sempre lontani cinque l'hanno sempre ben
dieci perché non è anche uno zaino che
spiegano non è no non posso prendere più
divento trovo perché non lo zero via
dove andare via via via senti tu come
sei messo cosa il fucile a pompa
palestra male sono anti sapere cosa
faceva con quello che facciamo è stato
alcan sei un fenomeno via usciamo
andiamo verso l'altra zona già facciamo
finta che quella blu e aiutata
quella casa blu li avete fa niente non
ha lasciato dobbiamo andare verso quelle
altre cause naturali è stato si stringe
verso dio ci metteranno una vita priva
di stringersi 0
tra i primi dieci non finiscono dario di
coste ne vai a caso mai a caso non vai a
casa finché navigatori v10 bello quel
pezzo di di terreno non renderizzato qua
e non c'è si vede
tutto qua non uccido scelto facebook è
sì infatti lontana per cento non c'e
nessuno però occhio che inglobate è
facile tu se entrano in questa casa
se quindi dove nell'altra seguito di
vista a casa
niente niente vuota completamente vuota
in mano della terra appena nate in
cucina grazie
c'è una cappa quando hai preso non l'ho
visto che me l'hai visto io prendo ti
lascio tutto col big mama quanto grosso
livello uno e cioè per 4 qua a prenderlo
arrivo lo zaino livello 3 ma non è visto
niente
da ieri ha presentato qualche da non
averlo livello 3 il massimo rosa via via
che andava di tutto prendi a noi è stato
nella carta per poi prenderlo che
facciamo poi ladro crack come vederlo
alla fiscalità questo [ __ ]
si misero 7 11 la porta con un per 4
dove ho trovato tutto
iamm li ha subito subito a muoverci di
continuo 6
ma le case live
no non è controllato piano 6 racconta ci
servirebbe ma allora tu notaio tutto
questa piccola tutta quella classica
dobbiamo trovare la macchina perché
siamo senza macchina e continuare a
continueremo a correre all'infinito sono
e non mi va trovato vedo adesso è il
ragazzo troviamo oggi a melbourne giro
poi non si colga no io non sono
valutabili
sì sì ma poi atto che tra di grosso non
mi sta vantando perché vedere se per una
vecchia
potere della cella potere degli occhi al
cielo
magari
boh non c'era una mazza porco non c'era
una malta
no non c'era una mazda 6 ancora carico
libro di ricordi e correndo anche perché
devo trovare una trovata macchina se
credo è una macchina quella messa in una
doccia dice a bora l'iphone è una
macchietta
[Musica]
e l'aereo che ci troverà libro davanti e
colori
[Musica]
e caduto perché 62 cucito immensi nel
metodo figo io ho la barella
un po ovviamente io non parlo potrei
anche mister solo perché non c'è chi
allora o decidiamo noi
[Musica]
[Risate]
saliva
dobbiamo andare all in che direzione
volato
volava verso nord
[Musica]
la trota
sì
[Risate]
anche fisica rimane sopra tu
continua gilardino
evviva la vita
la realtà infatti questo di chi bello tu
pensi che siano spacciati e invece siamo
fottuti pesanti e ti giuro che una volta
hanno fatto della macchina andata
dall'altra parte però può farsi curare
solo che
sai quante volte l'ho fatto e la
macchina è arrivata tranquillo
dall'altra parte ma stavolta chissà
perché al corso è solo la macchina
normale arriva dall'altra parte no
perché magari non lo so da una parte
possa comunque abbiamo fatto dimettere i
giusti over sono non mi sarei alzato
dato a farlo però comunque di base
ragazzi se vi capita di entrare nel team
e fatelo perché la macchina se non siete
in live arrivato a trovare un solo
quella normale sai se mancano da
raggiungere un x 480 61 pertanto siamo o
ci chi no a razzo sarà peggio gente
entra in tre esempi simon ballo c'è
piedi sopra qua
sì ci sarà
vendo prendono
non c'è niente
lutto nel fondo
bello
2 polito tra cosa con il bravo perché
allora magari sono decente cacciatori
stessi
sono io
si va dalla parte opposta dice ok
forse per una volta è un bene che ci si
sia fermata la macchina fermata cioè già
negato parcheggiata sott'acqua
delicatamente sono stato io
sì perché ha spostato il no
delicatamente posta minghi e spider man
no ci ho provato a farla così interviene
non siamo sparati contro miglia senza
peccato lobo alla figlia la vita e che
sarà a fronte di fare bene per chiamare
dell'unico oggetto che non me ne frega
un cazzo come dovrebbero ma ho mai fatto
ebbene noi e tutto lasciava
mai fatto un altro
la prova della morte perché ormai ha
preso il mikado
[Musica]
macchina ma ginocchio questa nonna mega
andata è sempre pronto
no ancora un occhio dopo questa data non
mi sento sento anch'io
chiudi
boh deve riuscire oggi un'altra macchina
lasciata in disuso dismessa lo vado a
prendere anche se spero non gli spari
scopri come allora non so se ci serve
perché non è veramente siamo messi non
male ma dobbiamo andare dalla voce non
siamo messi male però boh non ti so dire
se ci serve o meno prendiamo non sarà
rivolta a vita figura a casa vi si vai
vai di kit già fi ci credete che il
lancio una padella cazzo no no non
search e cover proci beh entraci e
sparagli e prova è l'uni è l'unica non
puoi fare nient'altro aspetta stata sul
container blu prove dal bravissimo c'è
da esatto non credo e proprio stop e
figo
cazzo è stata di tre salti mentre salti
per spalle il disbrigo arcaica vai
no dai lei che picchia i canoni continua
i colpi che avrà facile adesso è stato
per terra e si stacca carola di fallo
l'ho preso no dovresti cisl sarà entra
pan pan forte poi faccio h e gli
cambierà non è però mai colpito prima di
caricare sono pari a niente niente se
devi fare una cosa è questo il tappo e
ci ha provato occhio formaggi salumi per
arrivare a 30 euro è stato un bel
tentativo ma adesso dopo il tentativo
bene che trovano con 35 non aver di mesi
mi chiamo 21
gli scriventi nomadi team quello pino
nano tipo 50 si ricarica neanche la
porca vacca di home page
io mi immagino già i bicchieri basta no
cazzo no non esiste
dobbiamo vincere per vincere datevi a
lei devo togliermi quella scena
posso farlo si interessava ma tutti in
carrozza che tutti interessato andiamo
andiamo
bye bye in mezzo proprio al mondo da
bordello
aspetta che se mi metto questi di vento
più forte giusto per me ma che bello
mestiere allora volta deve andare ben
caldo prendermi un minuto solo dove sto
fuori la stoffa dell'abito gioco io
gioco io ho vinto bella a tutti i
ragazzi alla mia ragazza che è andato a
fare i fenomeni possono farsi delle
l'ipad ei canali di dove sei dove sei
si aspetta lei weiter mcgregor dice
bravo di fucile a pompa e il gelo
ragazzi voi al coni colpisce
tu che dovranno scatoli prima né con la
catena ed i coinquilini napoli dentro
gazzettino piccolo in cui mi fermo dopo
io divento mai pahlevi scorporato
addosso cosa
non comprendo grazie
dopo che dobbiamo afferrare como 14
[Musica]
dischi
ciao propria casa da 321 chi mi sono
mangiato no
fabbro
bene
di sicuro ha ucciso con una pistola con
il mondo
il mito alleati come po di volte ma non
sono mai morti chissà perché no
ma il corpo mi ha dato la porta
forse ci stiamo votando in mezzo alla
merda perché abbiamo le palle perché
abbiamo le file viola casari che doveva
questo gli spacco così cattiveria poi si
è cagato addosso lui andavano via
ma e lesbici questo sta tornando atterrò
io insieme
però io primo arriva dove cosa aiuto una
cazzo di vista però c'è gente quindi
dobbiamo vincere subito lo scontro a
fuoco che non vincere porca vacca allora
se allora gesù cristo throw giuro che
fastidio ma solo il live su c'erano ste
robe perché mi si è aperta la porta dal
nulla po giù di morale che ho trovato
nel mese di ci fanno bene tanto volo
entra subito dentro casa di tra di
uccidermi maggiormente forze le 6 arriva
16 qua c'è una sola ma non ti ha beccato
no
basta
ma figlio di [ __ ] ians ci hai provato
so che mi 16 tra buttato cicola
pistolina è sì l'ho visto casa di
schiena perché non è visto che cosa
faccio ci provo a iolo perché semmai
teolo perché sei morto così li facciamo
fino alla morte
fino a stasera sabato notte sparando
fuori dai capisci cioè cazzo ma dov'era
la grossa era morto io era tipo di palma
ed un cazzo foto miss panda dietro nomi
l'attività 4 cazzo trova una pistola di
merda migliorate le palle
tutto qua c'è un altro molto figura
l'asi quello sono io
per niente
essere andato lo zio ture
non la sento di brutto ma non disperate
qua sotto
tra gli occupati nei 16 la prima volta
che mi capita mi atterrare a trovare le
16 eccolo
ma guardate qua insomma questa papam e
chuck norris saino quello che ti guarda
i nuovi sei morto forse è andata resi
dai voglia di vincere spegniamo lodari
ma devo giocare all'inter di planet
no no io sai quando ti metti contro
proprio la divinità che di infliggere ma
le ragazze non avevano la stacco mai mai
vado fino a che non sono 27 ore di live
frega un cazzo me ne frega un cazzo me
ne frega niente secondo non sono in live
di vento il numero uno in sediolo solo
quando interruzione in die for c'è più
ora di merda quindi saltano da stampa e
spatole palle la chiamerà la ricerca
della vittoria
chissà mai che casa più di poi non
succede mai però quando farai il sesto
gioco dopo aver setacciato la gente che
abbiamo compagni più forti magari no no
non c'entra anche quando ci sarà cade a
quando ho visto la gente la gente muore
la mia verbale che il parma perché
questa è la volta dei tavoli prendere
tutte le munizioni e lasciare le luci
perché devi avere questi capelli e li
puoi anche scegliere di pregio
ok vi sono sotto gli occhi di da sola
fino adesso non muore subito insieme
ok
ma perché finale sono stati molto uniti
[Musica]
a metà ripresa
siamo qua si deve dire c'era ci resta
la casa
va beh dipende vediamo quanta gente c'è
nel caso io ad essere tu quello e mezzo
ok guarda che dava il mio personaggio
la banda
scendere in dub è bellissimo perché mi è
piaciuto
tanta gente sta cedendo
qui allacci delle case per delhi è certo
certo
tutti ovviamente dovesse mandandola
tutti e mezzo in 16 su questo testo
siamo atterrati
ma se me lo sto facendo perché dove il
figlio così hanno già arma sono scesi
con l'arma ho sentito come sono sceso
sentito spari cerca la qualità di subito
come sempre però non hai capito lo sto
picchiando fortissima tu lo stai
chigiana papa e mi sa che noi anch'io
non riesci portano a donarmi è un
abbiamo sbagliato posto dove andare e
giusto che loro le trovano mai no è
morto anche l'altro però attenzione
possono fare non era trovato neanche una
a prendere io non credo e non ce la
faccio non c'era perché l'asfalto di
brutto in bocca
okaka
è colleghi testa di culo incredibile che
ho fatto una clip che strano non ha
anche staccato la leiber fatto una chi
perché tanto morire subito dopo però è
stato bello fare questa che stanno
sparando a me insomma la madonna cosa
aveva questo tutto aveva
sono morto perché non potrò mai più
uscire da questo posto senza morire
perché stavano tutti puntati col fucile
qui devo aspettare che io riesca però è
stato bello provarci c'è stato per
l'amazzone un no ci sono e non ho
staccato light lo giuro il live lucido
stato stranissimo
ma adesso mi ammazzeranno diventerà il 2
1 no si attaccano askar però non dura
tanto sicuramente non aveva ancora dove
l'asse iscritte a ruolo che è il culo
peccato che voglio adesso perché la
pratica era messa bene questo sono
ottimista esterrefatti da maierato si
chiama realismo
l'unica casa dove credo non ci sia
nessun invece ci sarà gesù
[Musica]
che portava a varare
per me la devo fare tutto da solo
maledetto del 6 ma volto ma sono
atterrato sul tetto insieme a un altro
lui è trovato per le pile o lo picchiava
adami stavolta no
vabbè
se quello a trovare casi fissare la
macchina una volta che si qua dany dany
un mega consiglio scusami altri ma se io
adesso e non ha fatto nomi
no non cambiano lealtà non stava dicendo
mucchio 1 scarti compenso nell'abilità
di bass che cazzo faccio niente meglio
perché non provato c'è chi no ma non
trova lo hanno aiutato tutti i venti
volte e figure o dopo qualcuno comunque
grande boucle di quelli sotterranei
scavati sarebbe da mettersi con la
macchina dove saranno messi gli altri
capito spero sia lunghissima ci stanno
sparando no
luce una macchina ritorno
dalla matematica
guidata e vabbè
e che faccio più a macchina e vado a
[ __ ] devo rimanere faccia acqua picco
viene sempre dove nella città questa qua
nova re noi e non è che non risponda
ed è chiamato città
no
noi che cosa faccio degno dei bimbi
risponde
madonna ciao raga basta cento
io
già
ma neanche affari prima
ma andiamo a novara è una parola mi sa
che c'è gente ci saranno
[Musica]
[Risate]
tra due amanti
[Musica]
non c'erano 4
sparano da una destra
la madonna mi sono fatto
una macchina
io
[Risate]
[Musica]
tutto deve levare quante macchine
in queste zone sono rubate
[Risate]
[Musica]
ok diamo alla morte portese gr
i cazzi tua guida questi giorni sta il
problema
non capiscono l'arte
willis catafratta occhio mi sa che però
non vede astici un apporto verde
no anche fuori di stabilità sparando
ormai sono talmente a ridere a farvi
vedere vedere questa cosa che non mi
stati sparati per cuba
esatto
[Risate]
vediamo
[Applauso]
tanto qua dello stesso server faccia
qualche parte devo trovare qualche anno
muoiono almeno non ci ho provato
come pensate
ma sì ma devo trovare partirono colpi ma
a parte quello devo trovare mirino
cecchino per pino tutto dopo queste case
non sono date ottimi cancelliamolo che
mi aspetta ci si può aiutarla non lo sai
qual è sono armeni metri svetta un e
secca paese col mirino
però non l'ho uccisa ordini sono stato
bene nazionale cioè tanto per cambiare
oggi no sicuramente gioco come ma non lo
vedo ma non c'è una macchina che di base
cheadle verso viene aperto ha detto
infatti il tuo aperto andiamo ad un
porto rapporto di 9 reti moglie avesse
scusami ma è un porto basso dove era non
lo so la sinistra
vabbè basta con la posizione
e lì non è quello sulla via girelli
sarebbe a destra ancora ecco
ecco dietro dietro non lo vedo mai ma
tanto non ho comunque sperano proprio
allora basta e killing attendere lo
coglie quindi sei papato oppure poi via
verso le cure si sta malissimo verso
destra
wow
vano
ma lui ha già avuto il tempo di buttare
tutto di tutto
non credo sicuramente c'è qualcosa che
ha lasciato sicura ma qua è votato il
cazzo è gesù cioè non può aver lottato
qualsiasi cosa se non può essere passato
comunque non ha il tempo materiale del
metro quadro non è il più forte
sì forse sì perché mi ai danni
non c'è più
no era fatto
che ti viene come sia scomparso quello
che bello che trovo qualche che non ho
trovato ancora nessuna pistola per terra
ma bisogna mancato niente mica l'unica
una battuta e da un'ora che l'uso è
l'unica roba decente con minore don
picchi dare adesso basta
sta restringendo qua
[Musica]
troppo visibile
i clienti e della campania
dove dice io già subito dopo
qual è la mia macchina giusto dice di sì
parte che guarda cantaro volta non per
niente sono tra nulla in due ore non ho
trovato niente mille fornelle sensi
lestingi questa è la più probabile
c'è
allora comunque o il tipo è passato
ovunque e all'occhio di qualsiasi cosa o
non mi spiego come ma non ci sia nulla
adesso la fa niente neanche la lai che
può arrivare a una sfiga del genere
quando registri un video ai un certo
livello di sfiga simpatia 11 tanto
quando fai alive livello aumenta in modo
esponenziale
possiamo stare in una partita dal
registro per la spaccio per l'hiv metto
in like senza la webcam la nobile e dai
la donna facciamo controllato big fate
che aiutato dubbio si sia già viste
sa tipo dove esistono
ma sai che ti dico
42 hai ancora
sai andrei dalla camera qui però qua c'è
gente qui ma qua c'è gente qua c'è gente
qua c'è gente in area tecnica poiché
sarebbe da fare fera per proseguire bene
ea ammazzare qualcuno aiutare tutto
quello che ha e allora mi sono messo
bene quindi dovevamo alzare questo tizio
mista ha sparato prima però non saprò
mai perché è meglio equipaggiato lui
almeno se avessi almeno un sks ma in
realtà di bandiere di vendere sogni di
soppiatto e ma non posso anche se io
devo andare dove capita quindi lui mi
sente arrivare ma lui continua a girare
la testa staccata una nazione anche dove
sia preventivamente alla bicicletta
un'asta camp erano in coda qualche parte
e gli conviene perché tanto sa tanta
roba ma che cazzo vangelo come nei
camper ad aspettare che si ammazzi gli
altri io non ho nulla quindi non posso
fare neanche così ma nulla nulla inclini
a gesù grazie sks sì ma mica due o altro
arma chairman che incredibile
fate che i cargo anche aprendo la rosso
perché non il mirino è un po come se non
ci avesse nulla e poi ho pochi colpi
ingaggio qualcuno lo ammazzo dopodomani
firmware o che culo che questo questo
può essere un po chiusura incredibile è
comunque pochissimi colpi quindi che
tanto non ho trovato in giro ma manco
per sbaglio
ottimo aiutarti un piano alto di una
casa è ma lo trovate i colpi perchè non
sei in viaggio qualcuno mi ammazza cioè
non possono anche affrontarlo è uno
scontro diretto perché troppi pochi
colpi punti ma per favore di sfondate un
altro mp per cortesia perché ne ho visti
talmente pochi che è un peccato solo un
ben più ha trovato mi fanno cagare
luminoso ma il web qui perché si può
venire a prendere lui mp assoluto perché
tanto non contro ma nient'altro
avresti avuto 2.000 milioni di euro
rambo titoli ma c'è qualcosa ancora noi
ecco quella casa lì sarebbe ottima come
posizione the problem is che c'è
qualcuno
ecco se non c'è solo rimango con giuro
tutto però sì anche perché quanto si sta
dirigendo verso di parlare ci sarà
qualcuno quasi per forza cioè non per
forza
ma quasi 35 leiber senso scolari non è
permesso
quando muoio per la conta 14 aspetta e
al piano di sopra
mica totti 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 7 20
20 ho portato fino a avevamo sentito
finalmente peso morto
stava arrivando una macchina ma credo
che la macchina sia del tipo sera
l'andata e l'altro ti possono i tuoi
ricordi piacevoli niente giorno vabbè
vabbè next
sono le cinque mezzo ancora fino a
mezzanotte cento ce n'è e ce n'è
sti cazzi ma anche se arriviamo uno
spettatore ne frega tanto only wings è
sicuramente sicuramente mi piace il
gioco
il tutto si è incrociato stia bene
ovviamente anche anche il fatto che il
gioco non sia visto ce ne sono in live
giovanni magliani j
bellissimo nuovo originale qua
vabbè
queste attese interminabili
abbigliamento programmi a questi pack
averti bug
vabbè al 25 del tempo che vuoi tanto non
c'è mica gente in live che aspetta tanto
sembra che riesca a un braccio dal collo
infatti è così devo far prendere aria le
pezze ricordate non si descrive allora
punta nava cattiva di avviati o che cosa
cazzo beh qua sotto ragazzo che starò a
casa a caso venga sotto di quella porta
a valanga che di quella porta via
finché non ho una dispiacere così la
conta persone che leggo 335 euro
peggio siccome sentiti dalla mia vita se
cinque partite cinque sconfitte non è
male
vabbè che vincere dice va bene in top
ten che per risultati non fanno chissà
quante schifo però porca vacca in top
ten cerchiamo sempre mica in live non ci
dobbiamo arrivare a fuck u pagamento
schermo intero finché non riesco da via
ma che cazzo succede
ma mi si vede ancora 6 crociata largo
no sia lì ritardissimo ma se
4 è così
non c'e neanche qui l'esplora risorse
capito della scuola risorse già sparito
certo che se non ti si vedrebbe qua se
no poi in un processo su app store e al
punto da essa ma che lascia tutto il
computer strumenti aiuto raga stavamo
andando a merda ma se siete ancora se
contro il cancro
queste attività processi su file file
file file file e via computer con mattia
diversi paesi esaminati da explora il
punto s
number one tecnici sì però mi sta
crescendo tuttora gradevole devo
staccare riavvio ri ri arrivo subito sta
trasmettendo anche se non ho idea
penso di sì
siamo ritornati borgato è sì si sta
trasmettendo no buongiorno andiamo
via computer mattina un paio quando
pensiamo in un'attività explorer punto
non so se sono in live non ne ho idea
vediamo
selezioni live yes yes vedere scusatemi
ma che è successo un bordello è successo
noi non mi fido finché non lo vedo io
non mi fido se siamo il live bene da
niente oltre a perdere e nei giochi
perché porca vacca figurati se rimango
vivo miike ha lasciato tutto stima
questo si può immettere toccando un
meteorite fuori però quando faccio il
live normale amico primo player non
batteri gram si vogliono carico se ne
frega un cazzo non vado a casa sei a
casa due in modo a casa io esco di casa
non vai a capire un sacco
io sono a casa le schede tra carica
stavolta sotto si sa che questa cosa
giusta perché abbiamo riavviato il
computer è quella giusta però mai fatto
sette volte la corale di guarda mai mi
sento carico anch'io
adesso muoio crea subito a terra misti
non si apre paracadute
ci pensi di giocare così il board mort
carica prima mia borsa lo stronzo
di ultimate the life and death fight
life e non l'ho vista
anche io ho visto maledetto play era un
matri crowns che non ci fa vincere il
live porca vacca infame africa cazzi
continua fino alla morte
ci siamo
si tratta dai ok
non meritava
dal basso
allora andiamo
[Musica]
niente mentalità andranno tutti ma
cerchiamo di capire dove non ti do la
missione
vai
ma che cazzo ok
sembra che ci siano solo due persone
sembra e poi non so
dietro non abbiamo
zero
e occhio
sul quale casa alterniamo sulle prime
sulle prime si poi votiamo tutto cioè io
poi guarda guarda dove sta cadendo da me
dal mio monito così capisci
ok quelli sono caduti più indietro un
teams umiltà basta che la tinca
ma c'era però però noi siamo fiduciosi
dai no ma bisogna essere positivi e
fiduciosi nelle cose non ci ammazza
vinciamo noi vinciamo noi siamo forti
perché loro dovrebbero farci fuori
quando finì poi io n'esco a saltare
ottima le prime portico aperto troppo di
tutto
le voglio io prendono mtm mai trovati i
sessi e cosa mi stai decise buon non
morire e cattivo occhio che la zona si è
ristretta non da noi ma da parte cosa
per una moto la troveremo
cazzata
domanda
stavolta sono impostato meglio sono più
carico prestante mi sento nuovo c'è
qualcuno vi sotto tutta nuova
va fatta non morire come che cazzo
niente facciamo pesci non so come ha
fatto non maria rosa prossima ragazzina
che non torni a casa non torni non ci
torni poi taglierò tutta la prima parte
dell'area
nell'ultima parte mento l'unica partita
li hai un call agenti sto gioco
veramente ragazzi non muore se gli spari
nell'occhio c'è incredibile penso di
quella di macef
no veramente assurdo c'è il tipo come
cazzo affatto arabi come far andare
avanti ma quale organo come mp però io
ho sparato un caricatore in faccia una
cazzata memorie o sono riusciti degli
atti non lo sappiamo
immagini michiara come motovolanti
dovrebbe essere una leva tornati gta non
è una che guarda caso meglio
cosa
che cazzo mai che guarda guarda non c'è
qui se l'ho visto il caricatore 26 a
caso è sparita porca la gara finissima
scaricava al caso molto nel cielo
andiamo
vita
e porta bene
è una città
dovrei andarci tu
vogliamo
vela e gac incentra
mia madre in questo circondariale buono
va bene
come
veloci
ciminiera dello stesso svegliarsi c'è
qualcuno no e qualche castello una
camicia per la persona si no avevano
forzato di giunta si trovava una
macchina
daro no funzionale madonna mia che lui
perché c'è qua davvero bisogno di
tornare in sé un balcone
roma sì le scale visto posto non
esistono le scale non puoi salire al
piano superiore
come sei messo non ho trovato neanche me
ma non so cosa e si spara questo posto
messo ben più dopo la padella un
proiettile senza neanche un altro fosso
di lingua e massaggi
ma te lo giuro su dio non è mai successo
44 grano o un'arma gesù cristo ma farlo
a pagarlo a peso d'oro incredibile è una
cosa un po mi fa schifo
lance in pompa che peggio tra l'altro
guarda guarda guarda lo vedi
guarda il gioco incredibile perché dice
hai trovato un armano però non l'ha poi
aver trovata e quindi sto impegnando
nuoto sta impegnando il niente non si
non mira cosa non mi mira neanche o che
le soste impugnato stava impugnando il
vuoto dice vai trovato un'arma nato non
l'hai trovata in pugni niente tanto non
mi stupisco anche più cazzo mi stupisce
visto i cookie subisce affari
on ovi store di bello
dall'altra parte del mondo mai essere
tutelato nei messaggi pensando
dopo il fucile a pompa perché non avevo
preso questa
beh la fisica di questo gioco fatta bene
è molto bella mi serve un arma che non
sia un fucile a pompa
ma io poi ci sono atterrato prima
puntata scusa
chi agisce mai
e armi
dobbiamo andare a sinistra verso la tua
parte la porta raggiungimi micro un sì
ho provato
si stima che c'è adesso
dobbiamo anche andarci da quando
raggiungiamo questo complesso
adesso arriva abbiamo minuto per farlo
sino ad avere stringersi prodotto non ci
metto un botto
ok
questa
vuole esterne
c'è una macchina ho trovato 9 giu
tutto qua che piace ok andiamo a las
vegas
io qua
succederà ma c'è
ma noi dare perché ha sparato insperato
l'altro a caso non si sentì
cioè non ho sparato io neanche il mio
mouse che diventa scemi
però se c'era qualcuno che mi ha sentito
da gennaio locale
per due che lo sparanise 12 capacità con
sé tutta roba inutile chops clinici ho
così tanta ma anche se vi sarà un
cecchino no
porco demonio il caso mi ha dato
nell'occhio
che belli che sono diventati grafici di
questo gioco proprio belli vabbè arrivo
con la centro ci stiamo parlando ieri
con la macchina o un m16
e già qualcosa una cappa bene adesso una
cappa di energy drink mi chiamate si
spara arriva volo wireless sta arrivando
andato avanti si animano la macchina se
si no
occhio se non si fermerà credo perché
non in 60 cent
ecco come arrivo porc la quinta
sparandosi
mi aspetto qualcuno anche dal nulla non
mi ha neanche peccato però che non basta
amico mio
è già un dato tutto spero che esci
perché occorre come delle lepri
impazzite veloce veloce la cdc qualcuno
ci sta
i kids dove cazzo sei ok cercando di
saltare sulle cose
ok mi passa lì
albero
tema
mica quanta gente di anni
si sente a sinistra e non penso ci
spareranno sparino presto
cinquecentomila
[Risate]
andiamo si sono messi
per niente male non è che qualcuno ci
sei andata bene
a dare linfa
[Risate]
per questa ragione
però io
[Risate]
non sapere
beh se in una posizione
ottima per ricevere i colpi questo
faceva una macchina alla vita
una cosa non devo prendere pregio quella
3 a
non sono un bar
quando parlo poi ci ammazza
si no
macché
ma viene quando quante macchine voleva
[Risate]
si è probabile che non ci sia nessuno
però se c'è qualcuno
avete sono con te ma gol a registrare
bene non sembra in teoria esserci
nessuna occhio occhio mille occhi una
cappa una cappa cioè la tappa tuo
prenderli quartiere tanto mi fa sorgere
dei dubbi potrebbe non esserci nessuno
ho io
si no indietro venisse ks di prato
la porta ogni darvi una parte di quello
che mi chiami caro agosto non ha
coinvolto di meglio vuol dire che non è
aiutata no che volevo
ok mista che possiamo aiutarlo questo
vostro finalmente occhio però perché
siamo nella sei zone quindi qua ci
arriverà la madonna è il metodo 2003
come cazzo si toglie la prima persona
l'inizio
allora tolto un per quattro che non ho
spazio per tenerlo porta
presto però occhio ed ora no non c'è
niente come via via o no nella nostra
sono quelli che ho lasciato io niente
check in e qua manca il cecchino però
mandato la gt da qualche parte lo sento
certo c'è perché lo sentono tra un
preferisce percepiscono lo canto allora
del mercato
abbiamo centrati è così abbiamo centrati
boh non lo so se ve li chiudono
qual è la stanza sì sì sì è vero che
cazzo faccio boni che mio viaggio
perfetto nell'area di un chilometro a
sentirlo ma perché avevo appunto domani
a piedi scusami ma quella macchina qua
fracchia se effettivamente a piedi non è
male però
abbiamo più 6 nota piedi si sparano a
destra ma te no a destra
perché la cia mi scalda i motori iori
non ce la fai a inquadrare in una marca
fine basta dire che cazzo più di uno
le prime orsi che non ci andrei ma
neanche per sbaglio però in questo
momento io ci andrei
è un ragionamento che non stava bene
la serie tanto
invece tira non passare alla ruta tutta
era troppo lontana
lo spero
una barca di cinema che non si è
ovviamente no
[Musica]
state sicuramente come se non punto
proprio per non farmi notare poi l'unica
casa incontriamo qualcuno sì ma cos'è
questo è solo di ck cicala
cosa no
pagate per adesso
[Musica]
io se si dovesse si dice la zona si sta
per restringere si fanno ancora privacy
sempre stringere dove su di noi nemmeno
una nuvola strumento che abbiamo
scoperto
dove sta allora io vengo da te perché
sono scopertissimo mentre meno
soprattutto tv sia singer qua mettiamoci
una casa e campari a materiale è per
forza e una fanno solo che stavolta però
occhio perché non abbiamo il ceco chiudi
le porte se senti anche solo una porta
aprirsi 12 ecco è proprio ok siamo
esattamente nello stesso identico spazio
punto minino siamo 39 o questa è l'unica
partita dove siamo messi meglio delle
altre curati perché non hai
insomma quanti medici power sharp e un
occhio ma se ti do due di questi non 52
ti schiaccio dimette il 5 porti cav hg
trinchero c'è problema adesso no sì sì
adesso quello di per adesso
il culo come restare in questa città
quindi proprio poco secondo me
arriveranno
sì però noi siamo già qua se non l'hai
non conviene neanche guardare le
finestre non mi riguarda riporta con le
portiere senti le finestre perché sei
dato che arriva a tanto si devono salire
una volta ci ha pensato pertanto se
salgono e che tu gli ammassi sulla porta
che li ammazzi sulle scarpe 4
si spalleggiano se io non vedo sento
solo
36 alive tensione si respingerà di mano
con la zona da un po saranno tutti qua
eh sì
dal cinema
ma chi è
beh che forse vai a casa
non avete visto uno stava testando la
non devi sparare se ne vedi con sei
pazzo no ma era la band di sopra
occhio anche alle finestre di questa
casa acquatica abbiamo di fianco che
potrebbero entrare nella casa di el pam
pam
sei stato tu cosa ciao ciao soppresso
per isner con l'iphone che c'era però
non abbiamo un sacco di o anche il
mirino tutto ciò che solo il cecchino ci
sono ammazzato di blue dream ammazziamo
l'utile di associarci qui non sono morti
200 considera adesso non si sta
dirigendo in trend potrebbe arrivare
tutti se non erro da lì dove sta volando
c'è tutti più che potrebbe essere un
polo da lì adesso c'è questo momento
siamo in 30 in questo cerchio 29
ecco la prova
330 nella casa questa sola gamba ce n'è
uno potrà sparare aspetta che salgano
va detto qua nicchia
la morte dall'altro
la donna si sparano con un karkadan
ho chiamati
pezzo viene come panchina qua sta devi
sentire
passiamo
pro lontano
soprattutto la necessità di stringere
dove si sta stringendo sta roba
le colline o at bene primo momento siamo
salvi qua
sidoti
va bene visti tutti
330 questa casa power ma è una livella è
ancora lì no ovviamente il credo proprio
di no
magari si è vista camperanno non lo so
però piuttosto dopo di te ne sono messi
perché non è che quando hai pestato le
però a me sì a me no eccola qua si
stanca casa di fianco quella dritta
questa qui non sparare affinché nessuno
entra nella nostra casa che c'abbiamo
quasi bianco
occhio che ti vedo ansie di van son
cazzi di fare vedere se dietro il muro è
ugualmente pesante che controlla la zona
di poco
20 alive tensione 109 si sta
restringendo la zona e quindi qua peso
per uscire ma vediamo dove si restringe
credo non so se si si si può succedere
ma non lo so perché mi che la vedo
troppo tesa a sinistra secondo me si
stringe sulla piazza se si restringe una
spiaggia
abbiamo perso perché non abbiamo il
chino però almeno siamo in una posizione
molto migliore di quella di prima mica
prima finivamo che eravamo gli ultimi
cazzo siamo tra i primi 19 almeno 600
però voglio arrivare primi dieci
eccoli là in mezzo alla strada io li
vedo però che vediamo del sia si portava
a casa si stesse fatto una brutta cosa
ho visto e cemento in culo a quello ce
l'abbiamo nel culo assolutamente però
abbiamo meno decorandole farlo perché
tanto pur di uscire allora noi adesso
vogliamo fare così ti spiego quando ha
finito il minuto e quaranta a gas
arriverà verso di noi arriverà verso il
cerchio bianco quindi noi dobbiamo
andare accompagnati da gas quelli in
gara dietro culo perché tutti sono in
città come 65 stagionale
sono tutti città il problema si è
sparato no il problema è che lo faranno
tutti c'è tutto quello che sarà ma cosa
fanno tutti tutti si faranno
accompagnare dal classico dietro quindi
appena usciamo ci saranno scontri a
fuoco occhio chi arriva al 6 per cento e
bianco e avvantaggia tissimo e ha quasi
vinto però noi vinceremo comunque perché
non abbiamo cecchino ed una zona a campo
aperto quindi non sapremo mai arrivata
da 145 cento livello qualche pezzo di
merda loro ci provano e non posso
sparargli perché non un cecchino a avere
il cecchino in queste occasioni è lo
sciopero serve capito quindi la ricavi a
fare e in maniera accompagnatori piazza
è una pistola col cecchino e devo capire
dove va da te no e qua sotto
e qui sotto si no eccolo eccolo in
chiave così a tentazioni ammazzano per
prendere il cecchino verranno qua qua
però non occhio dice live questore
eccolo non sta salendo si sentì aprirsi
sta salendo
non si sa più niente salerno nel gas
cola uscire dal balcone poi è stato
ferito a che schifo uno ferito e basta
non è nostra lista
vai domani avrò dove arriva questo ci
sparano di frutto lo sai versi
li vedo anche troppo
da lei mi dice dai 10 ai live top 10 ma
premi dominic toretto sono mosso perché
il gas incide però sti cazzi i sensi tra
i primi se va bene così non potevo fare
niente perché mi fermavo a curarmi mi
avrebbe sparato due milioni che va bene
non poteva far nulla però va bene così
6 niente male o basta un lager per oggi
abbiamo sfatato strumento che non
abbiamo tra i primi dieci live basta poi
quando non ci quando insieme live bing
charlot addirittura però è la dei video
dove giochiamo seriamente sì perché sui
video che facciamo ovviamente la partita
vabbè lasciamo perdere la registriamo
flambè comunque sia ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto
grazie della carezza per fine live molto
gentile da quanto siamo in là da due ore
e un quarto
voglio vedere come sono i miei occhi no
ma la droga dell'internato religiosa di
libro
quindi ragazzi spero vi sia piaciuto
ringrazio nichi ringraziano daniela mi
ha accarezzato prima ecco molto ct euro
cosa che mi piace un momento piace anche
alle sorgenti sempre destinati decidiamo
possiamo dare dai falli chiude vice